Thank you very much.
You have spoiled my surprise.
You have spoiled my surprise because now,
now I was going to say,
this is why I have decided to
to run in the next elections
to the Parliament of Catalonia.
Thank you,
Thank you friends,
Thank you friends.
It is
this is what it is about.
If I may,
it's not just about
of of of
WILL run more elections.
It is a matter of proposing my candidacy for the
to restitution
of the magnitude of the generality,
to make it clear what this country is,
to get back on track,
to get back on track
that darkness and also division
blocked and fight with the same determination
we have been struggling with all these years.
to offer our fellow citizens
quality of life
and the country they deserve
as a result of the efforts they make every day,
by the sweat of his work,
for the hopes
that no one can steal from us and by the decisions
who have every right to release